[Music]
here on the TV show
don't go anywhere we've got a nice story
to share with you
[Music]
[Applause]
Colorado cool hat huh my brother was in
Turkey not too long ago and he brought
me back this nice gift this hat it's
very warm hamdullah so we're deep in the
forest here in Colorado so you were
actually a DJ before and you you were
telling me that your friend was the one
who hid the tracks who made the beats
for vanilla ice right right
d Shay Shay you'll see him in the video
in the background he's a DJ at the DJ
he's DJ he he's the DJ at the DJ table
in his name's Dee Shay so yeah he
created the beats for Ice Ice Baby yeah
he got a bus ticket home and Robbie Van
Winkle got 17 million so man we could we
can do right now we can go ahead and
send the message to - what's his name -
Vanilla Ice what's his real name
Robbie Van Winkle Robbie Van Winkle
because you were living that lifestyle -
but at what point did you actually
decide to accept Islam and why it's by
accident literally a motorcycle accident
led me to Islam went to Oklahoma to stay
with so I had the accident in Dallas
Texas I went to Oklahoma to stay with
some family to heal and I went out to a
club one night and what I thought were
some Spanish brothers Latinos turned out
to be some brothers from Saudi and they
told me don't tell people you met us at
a bar but they were just people watching
drinking soda they weren't you so these
were actually Muslims not supposed to be
at a bar but then they actually ended up
I mean that's nice that's you see how
people you sometimes you can succumb to
your desires but they still had that
love for for this way of life that we
should be living from the crater its
last mission to the will of the creator
not the creation and now they actually
shared it with you yes yes after the bar
closed we went to Denny's where we met
up with some more Saudi students that
just find a corner table drink coffee
and study and so after a while I just
quit going to the club and I just went
straight to Denny's knowing the brothers
would be in the corner table study and
drinking coffee and I started asking
them questions about their religion
based on what my junior high and high
school books taught me and I was way off
so they cleared some things up and it
was just logic just made so much more
sense it just really cleared my mind
again logic praying five times a day you
know where humans were weak to keep his
God conscience to drop what we're doing
just for a few minutes to pray five
times a day that makes sense the logic
in the prayer most of all Jesus
I knew Jesus didn't come to Oklahoma you
know so the truth has to be with the
folks that walked where Jesus walked oh
the belief in Jesus being the most
miraculous prophet messager of them all
made much more sense than jesus being
the son of the creator of the universe
the son of god that just did not make
any sense
yeah I've always believed in God I was
always God conscious but I just didn't
believe what I was being told as a kid
so I just kept my beliefs to myself
pretty much and every now and then you
know you pop in on a church a Baptist or
a Methodist
so so when I was introduced to Islam
that's I was so excited I just had to go
out and tell people what I'm feeling and
what I'm learning what I'm experiencing
I was very passionate yeah stay tuned
with us we'll continue getting glimpses
of our brother Sam's story who still
likes to ride the Harley huh yay yeah
yeah so we're here in Denver Colorado
and you can't get nothing like this huh
look at that beautiful scenery out in
the nature and you're getting some nice
bits of this beautiful story so
hopefully this can benefit you and your
journey in life make sure you guys
subscribe shows when they come out so
brother Sam how long has it been now
since you made the decision to accept
Islam 1987 what what advice do you have
for because many people they sometimes
you know understanding the concept a
belief in only one God worshiping the
Creator not the creation the Quran being
a living miracle and many of these
concepts like you said believing in
Jesus is one of the mightiest message
ever sent you didn't believe that he was
God's Son of God someone dying for you
since this is all dude with all due
respect for people of other faiths and
whatnot but it just didn't connect with
you the pure monotheism does people
accept Islam but now a lot of times they
go back because they have family issues
they don't maybe feel some community
support is not they're lacking but now
you were able to stick it out of course
you you have your ups and down trials
that's how it is in life what what had
you stick it out that now it's been
since 1987 right right pre every
everybody blames 9/11 for everything so
pre 9/11 it wasn't too difficult but now
I here are the stories from their
reverts after 9/11 some lose their
family and friends abandoned some lose
their jobs so they're struggling so
that's where I focus on revert support
try to offer mentor guidance because
they show up to the to the Masters back
back in 87 there's only two other white
reverts
in Dallas area that I know of
David McClung Howard Mustafa very
knowledgeable brothers and I've had my
struggles over the years being on the
road and there's no excuses you know
like I'm the brother to told me it's
like I'm on an escalator but I'm not
moving so but in the last few years on
hamdullah you know I've really learned
more than my first 20 years yeah reach
out we got to reach out to the new
reverts especially during the holidays
especially during Ramadan invite them to
your house for to break fast invite them
you know stick with them there's such a
best advice I could give tell us brother
Sam you you've experienced so much in
life you know you you've been through
life you used to be in the nightclub
scene and it seems like for people who
are still chasing that you have some old
friends I do also who still got the gold
chains and they're trying to pimp up the
ride and I'm still in the clubs and
we've left all that some people even
fall back and they see like hey I'm not
missing up it's just a life of
debauchery chasing your desires and then
at the end that void is still there it's
a high tell us about that and how and
how did you for people who are still
there and then you're able to connect
with them now they're watching the
program what do you like to say
regarding that it's a vicious cycle
it's a hype to keep following the latest
trends in music clothing cars you you
were you were that you were having the
people would come to you and say DJ play
me that favorite played in my favorite
song huh yes yes yeah the DJ was popular
did you play the music they want to hear
keep them out on the dance floor
so you are you are one of the most
popular people because that's the DJ's
demand in the club right yeah you got to
keep that dance floor occupied you got
to keep the people on the floor keep
them high keep them moving and keep the
whole and now it's just so annoying to
me it's just I turn on the radio every
once in a while I'm a truck driver I'll
tune into a radio and I'll give it a
listen and it's just it's just noise to
me now just one of the reasons why I
because I think about my past and what
that music how it controls people's
emotions and to hype you up to go on the
dance floor and you know if you've seen
the latest dances lately yeah doesn't it
would you say it numbs the heart the
mind oh absolutely absolutely yeah it's
just you know they're just going through
life so what were their heart and eyes
covered now we talked we talked about
earlier about Vanilla Ice he was popular
and it just shows that how someone can
be popular for maybe he was really known
for one track he floated right yeah and
then and then maybe two tracks or three
whoever but then it just you just it
gets played out and it was a bandwagon
to everybody who's bashing poor Robbi
yeah and he felt like he was a victim
because of everybody Jim Carrey bashed
him on in living color of some other
rappers bashed him for selling out yeah
yeah what would you if you want it if we
were going to send some love to them you
know tried it because at the D show we
try to have people reflect where did you
come from
why are you here what's your purpose in
life and where are you going because
we're all gonna expire from this light
we all got a DD a deaf date we're gonna
pretty soon bye to everything we can't
take anything with you when you go so if
we can get vanilla ice sir his real name
is Robbie Van Winkle he's still alive
right yeah what would you say to him to
really get to reflect and think and
consider this way of life he's went
through some trials he's went through
some up and downs after he's actually
he's really talented he is a talented
rapper he is a talented writer but right
now I think his latest show he was
flipping houses he's a carpenter now
yeah doing TV shows but he did some
soul-searching he I guess he went in and
out of Rio did some drug Cuse I think I
didn't know him in the past for him to
do that but I guess he got caught up
into it later through the depression and
then he met a nurse and that was the
love of his life and she grounded him
spiritually
yeah I would advise him to keep your
eyes and heart open and search some more
and eventually inshallah stop by a
Masjid ask questions go on in don't be
scared
we're therefore we got a program called
ask a Muslim yes some great advice keep
your mind open keep your heart open and
usually what I tell people to do is ask
it's very it's so simple it's strange
sometimes unbelievable but do something
so simple maybe you didn't even think
about it but now I'm gonna leave you
with it ask the Creator who created look
at this this whole beautiful world that
we enjoy and everything in it for
guidance say the one who created me
guide me why am i here what's my purpose
someone like Vanilla Ice and many of
these you've experienced all the finer
things in life and we know what people
like and you've had all of that but
there's no content at the end you still
want more and more and then finally you
find something and the love of your life
will be gone too
she might leave before you and then what
someone lives for for a woman or a man a
job or something in creation that's
gonna leave you - but the one who
created you that's the one that you
should turn back to and ask for guidance
and then see what happens take it from
there and take our brother Sam advice
stop in make the connection with a
Muslim I remember Muslim is simply one
who submits his or her will to the
Creator to heavens in earth Jesus was a
Muslim did you know that and he
worshipped the crater alone not himself
or anyone else in Christian but the one
that we're calling you to connect with
God Almighty Allah Sam you were
mentioning much of the prejudice in
different parts of the country did you
have did you experience some of that
before you accepted Islam
oh yes that's why I grew up with that
you know it's kind of like I could say I
speak their language in a way you know
but to deal with extreme prejudice the
folks that are just set in their ways
and they're being taught what their
father taught them what their
grandfather taught them and anything
foreign to them they're they're not
going to hear it they don't want to hear
it they don't want to know about it they
don't want to talk
that's hardly cold break that wall down
you know so due to media in movies
Hollywood you know they plan a deceit
it's just my theory for them to have
this in their hearts so some with
something like Islam someone with a
Muslim name an Arabic name that's
foreign to them and they don't want
nothing to do with it and their but you
remind them well Jesus is Middle Eastern
Jesus spoke Aramaic Hebrew the English
language didn't come I'm not sure I'm no
historian but thousand years after yeah
till I believe into the the around
fifteen sixteen 1600s yeah right Jesus
didn't speak English right he wasn't
from the from the good old boy from the
south for Texas right yeah so you you
you you got back what was it now when
people hear about this about Jesus I
mean this is like really there's so many
commonalities right
the the virtues of good moral conduct
and family and so many great recipes
teachings in Islam that conservatives
and people who really have these values
will connect with but the and many
people who are Christian like you were
they they don't resonate with a man
being God can you talk about that the
hard time you had with that and how
Islam solved that riddle for you the
whole concept of Jesus being born from a
virgin so automatically is planted in
their head well obviously he's from God
well they don't realize if God created
this never ending never expanding
universe if he wills a virgin to have a
baby she's gonna have a baby all he has
to say is it will be it will be so
they're kind so you're kind of limiting
God's power to think that he would have
to place his seed in a virgin to have a
child and did so I would kind of run
that by him and they would and our job
as Muslims is not really to push to be
for you know forced anything on anybody
our job is just to get you to go hmm
think of think yeah think about that
that's then our job is done
and hopefully they'll come back for more
questions yeah absolutely one of the
things as we had because that's what you
said that people uses the proof that
Jesus being God because he had no no
father right well we would say you know
God Almighty is saying reminding people
look if God Almighty is able to create
Adam without no father or mother right
he should be actually a greater God sure
right but Adam and Jesus called us to
worship the God that they worshiped
right the one who created Jesus the one
that Jesus prayed to right you were
talking about how that really had you
come back to want to connect with God
talk about that what when you when you
found the correct concept of God in
Islam and Jesus the definition of Islam
that got my attention his lamb means
submit to God Islam is the only religion
that has God's name in it so that right
there got my attention and brought me
closer submit and as God doesn't asked
Allah does not ask too much from us just
five daily prayers manners adequate
follow the Quran and to follow the you
know and the people before us the Jews
and the Christians the people of the
book and to remind them that we have the
similarity you are also people of the
book we do believe in you you know we do
believe in Jesus we do believe in Moses
and I know
and all of our similarities the story of
Jonah everything that's amazing what you
said the name you know that Islam is not
named after Muhammad or for instance you
have Christianity named after Christ
Judaism and and named after the time of
Judah you have for instance Hinduism of
a geographical location Islam is not
named after people a geographical
location but it's the way of life since
the beginning of life because it means
to submit your whole self and your life
to the Creator who created life when
people like you just said your testimony
to that just in the name Islam
submission to the will of the Creator
not the creation and that's how human
being finds purpose and peace in life
that was like a light bulb went off aha
moment huh submit to God's will yes to
the will it's actually in the Lord's
Prayer isn't it if Christians would do
the Lord's Prayer our Father or our Lord
who art in heaven hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come Thy will be done that's
Salaam to submit your will to the
creator and you did it and you became a
Muslim how one who submits to the will
of the Creator hamdulillah and we're
here in Denver Colorado
Sam share something with me and this is
something that you really can't
experience anywhere else except in this
way of life that unity that brotherhood
you are at the the to stop the Russ
station and you were making wudu that's
preparing for prayer we pray five times
a day minimum stopping what you're doing
to thank the one who created you for the
life and all the blessings you have so
many spiritual benefits and physical so
and mental and what what happened from
there yes I was gonna do a little
segment how because there's more and
more Muslim truck drivers in the u.s.
now and how do we recognize each other
so I'm in a truck stop making wudu doing
you know
letting the water fall from the cup of
my hands and the brother just came up
and just came they told you huh yeah I
just came right up and hugged me and
said assalamu alaikum peace be with you
I was overwhelmed with his kindness and
just just a really sweet kind man from
Florida I think he I think he's
originally from Jordan I think yeah yeah
and a truck stop in East Texas in
Nacogdoches Texas I think I was coming
out of the men's restroom drying up my
arms and and the owner of the truck
stopped gave me Salam I could tell by
your movement you're you know prepared
preparing the prayer that's what we do
before we pray we go ahead and get into
a a preparation you were making the
evolution and that connected them to you
they saw that and they gave you the love
amazing these little hints here and
there we recognize each other when you
experience that love that's that
brotherly or that sisterly love and
these are you're not even blood
relatives what we say that you have
brothers and sisters in humanity because
we're all the we all come from the same
father Adam then you have brothers and
sisters Blood Brothers but then you have
brothers and sisters in faith and that
love is just trying to send all of that
huh I've never never experienced that
you know that was really something
though all of is your heart warms your
heart especially on a on the road where
it could be a hard cold place sometimes
where it's a tough life yeah and to have
that Brotherhood yeah it's very it's
very nice to know that there's more of
us out there yeah he's got some food he
wants to come he's just for food and
animals like in like he's invite
refreshments at the stop on the Resta
yeah like brother do you have anything
to eat I got halal food I got everything
just come to my truck right here you
know he's very and this is for everyone
this is not something that's cluesive a
cult or what now this is the call for
all humans all human beings to think
what's the purpose of life why am I here
very simple and straightforward ask your
created the one who created you to guide
you and then when you get guide
to the purpose of life you submit to the
owner of life and you start living this
way of life and now you connect to your
family right reminding each other to
live a good wholesome life you're gonna
make mistakes you're gonna fall short
but God Almighty is the most loving the
most merciful and then you have your
extended family now to help you to
remind you because we're all growing
we're all works in progress
no he's out of Fort Myers Florida and
he's like brother any time you're in
town here's my number call me my home is
your home come on over have dinner even
though it's very you get the invite to
that's Barry
nobody does that yeah of course first of
all I invite him I'm like well you're in
Denver give me a call I'll come pick you
up and we'll I'll take you to the
Masters and show you around
and this should be I mean you have good
Christians out there you have just good
humans and this is something that needs
to be revived right we have this
exclusively in Islam but this is this is
this is that human touch the human
connection nowadays people are you know
there's so much crime and there's so
much murder and there's so much so much
hate out there that people are actually
scared they're scared I mean this is
like you know they're scared to give so
that hello to invite their neighbor to
to dinner or whatnot because of all the
madness is out there good but good human
beings need to step up and make a change
and different because when the when the
majority the good majority slaves silent
that's when the corrupt minority start
to take over so good people need to
stand up speak up and good needs to be
perpetuated and good trends need to be
set it's even it's easy to set evil
trends but good trends need to be set we
need to call each other to goodness to
live morally upright lives to be good
human beings to have good interactions
and business and life and family that's
what it's about
they'll make sure you subscribe hit the
notification bell so you don't miss up
on all these exciting episodes
that God willing inshallah we'll be
coming to you here at the Deen show